so I can now declare the result of the
North Tyneside constituency so ivory
thingie really the acting returning
officer for North Tyneside constituency
declare that the total number of votes
given to each candidate was as follows
Martin William Collins
the Green Party 669 Mary Theresa Glyndon
Labour Party thirty three thousand four
hundred and fifty six Henry John Newman
the Conservative Party candidate
fourteen thousand one hundred seventy
two Greg stone Liberal Democrats 1494
I therefore give notice that Mary to
Azad Linden is duly elected as a member
of parliament for the North Tyneside
constituency thank you I've only got
five pages so fluid and I would like to
thank Air the returning officer and all
her staff who worked on this election
force here this evening and through
yesterday and all the work is done in
the weeks the short time they had to put
this election together so thank you very
much and a special thanks to our police
who kept us safe and made us feel secure
throughout the proceedings and I would
like to M specially mention Eddie dark
my election agent
all the work editors make has made our
campaign a success and who's the person
who keeps our tremendous team of
volunteers and labor party members out
there
time after time on the streets not just
over the last few weeks for the election
but throughout the air as we go on our
Street visits and I can now also say at
that and I would personally like to
thank everyone who came out and helped
many of you night after night and and
this result is is yours I can always
rely on the wonderful support of my
fabulous family and especially my dear
husband Reed who was taking
photographing our thing but thank you
the and of course I think I would that
what we must do is always thank all the
other candidates and because they have
made this campaign a contest and you
know we've had all of us to fight for
every vote and none of us I think would
ever take anybody's ward for granted and
I'm sure that goes for any politician in
this room tonight and I think we're also
all grateful to everyone in North
Tyneside
who did cast their votes the prime
minister called this election to get a
mandate from the people of the UK to
negotiate breakfast brexit in a strong
and stable way and she has certainly
failed to do that here in North Tyneside
particularly the people of North
Tyneside voted on issues that are
important to them the NHS the police the
education and all the other public
services that keep us going in that and
make us a civilized society I promised
in my leafless that if I was reelected I
would go on and fight to protect those
services and continue hopefully to be
that strong voice in Westminster that
the people of North Tyneside
need and all I can see as I need to see
a shin
is up now and being given the permission
to go and do that and I promise I will
stand up for North Tyneside as long as
his Parliament lasts
[Applause]